you think you're gonna be a good dad oh
I'm an amazing Uncle so I think I'll be
a great day because they're all right
you're going to teach him hard lessons
I know because like I think I'll spoil
them they'll be they'll be they'll be
the ones bullying the other kids yeah
you just teach them like this is how you
put them
shocked at the video game you're like no
no yeah we gotta [__] Peter win right
now oh yeah no so I have my nephew as
part of my most recent Roblox video I
did I gave him ten thousand dollars
worth of Robux he's 10 by the way oh I
don't know okay I'm not
I'm allowed to say this because he's dad
might get mad at me but anyways funny
um he spent it all within a day
because he just didn't know what the
[__] he had no concept of what it was
actually like money wrong well because
in Roblox like some guy just convinces
you to buy some item that's actually
worth like 50 Robux for like 50 000 or
some shoes yeah and I think he might
have just wasted on one one or two games
or something and yeah you know it was
gone in the day so I'd probably do that
I'd probably just be imagine soon I
can't help but they just they feel like
you want to give him 100 now and see how
long it takes yeah it was it was kind of
funny because it was for the video so I
don't really care yeah but like
obviously you got a little bit of
trouble you're supposed to share it with
his sister but he did it
yeah that's the main thing you got in
trouble with I'm sure I'm sure he's got
another 10K right yeah unfortunately if
I if I had some left but it's really
hard to buy that many Robux nothing
wrong with spending ten thousand the
fact you didn't share though yeah I mean
big noise I just don't know how it went
that fast he messaged me because he has
a phone now yeah so he messed him he's
like uncle Lenny
what how can I spend these Robux after I
send it to him he's like yeah you can
spend it I was like just go really slow
spend over like a two months or
something like that have fun enjoy
yourself you know buy the things in your
favorite games pay to win do that stuff
that's fine yeah that's gone in the day
did you find anything substantial
his character I checked his account it's
got nothing interesting on it where did
it go what do you like someone's
probably just messing my God yeah no buy
this like hat for like a million or
something I could have bought one of
those like items on the exchange and
then he could have been like all right
Uncle I've managed to turn the ten
thousand he could be the best
I'm a mogul of Roblox I am that's how
all the richest Roblox like people like
made that money because they like traded
Collectibles either that or they make
the games themselves but
um yeah no I'll I'll be I'll be probably
spoiling them I don't know yeah I know
you should teach him a lesson in like
investment I don't know why but yeah
send him bankrupt yeah I wish my uncle
gave me
bankruptcy court now you're actually
gonna wait seven years there has to be a
there has to be a Roblox bankruptcy
manual what is your occasion there's
money Tycoon yeah
some of my favorite Real World videos I
did with like are with him like he's an
audience favorite my nephew
um we'll get back to that like just take
him on adventures and like yeah yeah
because this guy this game off topic now
but like kind of like the the one scene
the one and only scene that stands out
to me the most in [__] Yu-Gi-Oh
remember like the original Yu-Gi-Oh
anime yeah
um there's a scene where this is how I
basically learn about stocks basically
uh it's uh I know the senior talking
yeah do you know what I'm talking about
I'm glad we're talking about anime
though I've got opinions but okay okay
we'll get inside it's uh so it's like
Seto kyber's like backstory I think and
he has like an adopted dad who's like I
will adopt you but I'm going to give you
one million dollars and uh if you can
turn this into 10 million dollars I will
adopt you and that is the game yeah and
that's it and uh basically Soto kyber
explains basically like uh how stocks
work and companies real like Yu-Gi-Oh
cards being like I I have a hundred
cards in front of me right now what if I
just buy 51 of this company represents
by 51 uh 51 Yu-Gi-Oh cards and I forced
them to give them 10 million dollars
that's how stocks work oh my God what if
we do that with Roblox well let's just I
watch you go on cheese TV as a kid or
whatever right I never remember none of
that like I feel like as a kid like I'll
watch Hugo but I never in took anything
that actually happened no I I don't know
I mean because also you did you play
Yu-Gi-Oh as well as a kid I had the
cards but it pissed me off at the TV
show none of the cards worked the
[__] same yeah no yeah like the TV
show broke rules they would just change
the cards you like playing it yeah I was
like this is [__] okay kuribo
[__] sucks why does he keep using it
my favorite thing about like and I think
it was the same with like Pokemon cards
and [__] is you just like anyone who had
a color printer was just printing off
like these
my parents like refused to buy me
Yu-Gi-Oh cards there was times where we
had like some money as a kid and then
times we didn't and the time of Yugo
cards were around we had like nothing so
like my mom's like yeah you can't have
any so I had to lie to kids about oh
yeah I got Grandpa's deck at home
I've got Grandpa's dad
like where's your cards bro what are you
doing same as Beyblades I didn't have a
Beyblade for like four so Mike because
my dad worked at a printing company so
like we had like the best printer oh so
I forced my dad to print out all the
Exodia cards yeah bring that to school
and they'd be like whoa he's got all the
exodius Bro being nine was such a great
time one time my friends had cars I
really really wanted
ah [__] okay I'll trade what do you want
for it and he he gave a list of cards he
wanted for all I think it was The
Elemental Heroes or something yeah and
that was the cards and uh so we so I met
up with him I gave him the cards he gave
me the cards and I'm looking at him and
the top one's fine it's legit and as I'm
like moving these cards around all the
names are just in Chinese but not not
not Chinese Chinese they're in like in
like Roma like uh Roman alphabet Chinese
so it's like it's like it's a Chinese
spelled out phonetically in English but
I was like that's pretty funny what the
[__] is this
that's a rare car and I was like what
what the hell I can't read this [__]
what car did you give me and they were
like kind of discolored as well you
[__] me give me my cards back right
now like I got my mum to [__] scream
at like her man to give me the cards
back cause he [__] scammed me I was
like my dad'll beat up your dad yeah
being chilling
she's just like what the [__]
did you go through a Pokemon card phase
or anything like that uh I yeah I
definitely had Pokemon cards uh I never
like played the card games themselves
though I don't think anyone yeah
not since I've been an adult though like
I know Loki's like loves these Pokemon
cards but I mean all of YouTube got
obsessed oh yeah massively gambling for
Pokemon cards it was the most sanitized
form of gambling ever yeah yeah I mean
it was some good Investments for some
people no I never like got super into
like as an adult like I don't have no
maybe I had some sick cards as a kid bro
too busy on RuneScape yeah